quel candidat va sortir son épingle du
jeu de ce nouveau scrutin qui va
affronter donald trump à la
présidentielle en novembre c'est l'objet
d'un autre face à face ce soir et pour
en débattre
nous sommes avec denis jacquet en direct
de miami aux états unis entrepreneurs
auteur de pourquoi votre prochain patron
sera chinois aux éditions eyrolles un
grand observateur de la campagne sur ce
plateau à paris on sépare il y aura pas
de transmission de coronavirus le
plateau pour huit présidents des
républiques n things french merci marine
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on va parler quoi de mini tuesday
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce super
tuesday
puis ces mini fusée - des états mais à
six états quand même et les états très
important pour briser en deux le tas le
plus important c'est michigan
donc oui à plus de son délégué a gagné
donc il ya des états très basque de
l'état de washington jusqu'à l'état de
must be ou louisiane a doublé mais de
sud ouest au sud de michigan
donc ça c'est très intéressant très
serré c'est très important pour à bernie
sanders en fait la course maintenant si
vous voulez que je dise c'est plutôt
c'est plus une course de brennus et 1,2
contre quelqu'un contre joe boyd s'est
prononcé contre tout l'établissement un
démocrate qui après le super tuesday
l'année 1 semaine dernière ils ont créé
une coalition où tout le monde de
l'établissement démocrate soutient
joe boyd donc çà çà çà çà difficile pour
brahim est rien et est sûre c'est
possible qu'il peut gagner mais chicken
et on verra denis jacquet ce bernie
sanders que l'on voyait déjà loin devant
joe biden qui n'était pas en bonne
posture avant de remporter la caroline
du sud ça y est maintenant c'est le
moment où bernie sanders joue son
va-tout il n'est pas forcément le mieux
placé selon vous c'est votre analyse
également non mais d'un certain côté il
y aura gagné bon ça c'est une réflexion
très française on aime bien dire qu'on a
gagné même quand on perd mais c'est
clair que imaginé il ya encore 10 ou 15
ans qu'un candidat se déclare
ouvertement socialistes qui le
revendique et qu'ils en fassent un
produit j'allais dire pas marketing mais
un produit de vente c'était assez
innovant visage à bhl aux états unis
réac le terme socialiste le président
trump a réagi quand on regarde ces
débats ici et c'est fini mais en fait
ils ne sont pas socialistes ils sont
communistes
donc parce qu'il sent bien qu'il ya une
espèce de monter populaire que lui n'a
peut-être pas su complètement
capitaliser ou capter aujourd'hui qui
est en train de lui échapper mais tient
tous ceux qui effectivement ou un job
parce que le taux de chômage est très
très bas aujourd'hui mais qu'ils ont eue
dans les grandes villes qui capitalise à
peu près tous les jobs alors que le
reste des états unis mais comme la
france italie extra le reste des
communes et des petites et des moyennes
villes moeurs et ces gens là qui pensait
avoir un job et profiter de la frénésie
des jobs n'ont pas réussi à la voix a
donc sont en train de se reporter sur un
candidat qui peut s'exprimer ouvertement
socialiste donc en tout cas pour cette
frange politique l'inde qui pensaient
que c'est un mot tabou
il a une grande victoire à son actif ces
deux d'être presque rendre le mot de
socialistes convenable effectivement
comme disait notre ami tout de suite sur
le sur le plateau c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui a aujourd'hui rebondit
donc ces zooms hebeisen aussi parce que
finalement tout le monde avait considéré
qu'il était totalement mort
qu'il était complètement dans les choux
et qu'on le reverrait pas et aujourd'hui
voilà quasiment en tête dans les
sondages et dans les pronostics donc
c'est une campagne quand même
extrêmement surprenante alors beaucoup
moins que notre ami sur le plateau moi
j'ai moins d'antériorité que lui sur la
vie politique américaine
mais très clairement c'est une campagne
qui échappent par beaucoup de par
beaucoup d'éléments à tout ce qu'on a pu
voir avant y compris dans les pronostics
puisque toutes les chaînes que soit
force d'un côté cnn de l'autre dans les
deux cas disent qu'en réalité il
n'arrive plus vraiment à comprendre ce
qui se passe vous avez cette analyse par
une campagne extrêmement surprenante
avec des chaînes de télé qui soit un
petit peu perdues les observateurs et
des journalistes un peu perdu j'ai quoi
que ils sont pas vraiment perdu en
termes de médias le midi américains
surtout le midi établissements 1 il veut
pas briser en deux donc tous qu alice
derrière jonathan peut s'écrire turban à
500cc le candidat des médias à dubaï
donne exactement établissements
américains cnn et msnbc et bicici tout
ça il serait bien une union sacrée
les médias de gauche comme de droite des
médias de gauche comme de droite
il ya une forme d'union sacrée pour joe
biden qu'on soit de gauche ou de droite
oui en fait parce que jupp heynckes
gauche et il est beaucoup plus grosse
que avant pendant ces trente années de
deux sénateurs de congrès vice-président
et essaye d'être plus gauche mais ben
lycéens d'eux mêmes tout progrès cible
ou même plus grosse que joe banner est
l'ami des établissements il réalise que
ça c'est très difficile pour drainer à
gagner l'action gênera donc ils mettent
tous les forces tout le colosse touche
tous les milieux et tous les davantage
derrière
joe bail dans ce cas c'est clair peu
mais c'est toujours une question de
combien de gens vont va beauté brune est
sérieuse et très populaire avec les
jeunes et beaux que des hispaniques et
c'est une question s'il peut motiver et
donner l'info diaz montrouge ans à venir
ce soir et voter parce que nos moments
excuse moi les jeunes ils sont très
enthousiastes hic mais historiquement
ils votent pas beaucoup mais peut-être
sept années 20 il y aura plus de gens
qui votent donc on verra
denis jacquet c'est intéressant ce que
palringo dit parce que c'est vrai qu'on
a si c'est vraiment un engouement de la
part de la jeunesse pour os candidats un
bernie sanders qui a soixante dix huit
ans je crois et compris aussi chez les
hispaniques comment on explique
finalement que tout le monde ait lâché
bernie sanders est vrai tous les genres
tous les autres candidats abouti
ce sont tous ralliés à joe biden ça veut
dire que vraiment on est allergique au
socialisme quand même aux états unis
je pense enfin il ya peut-être deux
analyses 1 mais à nouveau sous le
contrôle de paul qui est qui qui est
américain il connaît beaucoup mieux son
pays que moi mais néanmoins un on voit
bien à travers le monde que des
candidats alors je suis désolé si on
utilise un terme un peu galvaudé mais
des candidats plus populistes ou un
succès qu'ils n'ont jamais eue dans ces
trente dernières années parce que tout à
coup il ya une fêlure il ya une cassure
on voit bien que les gens n'y croient
plus et en gros il cherche à trouver des
candidats qui sont hors établissements
comme dit paul parce qu'il considère que
l'établissement les a ruinés n'a pas
tenus ou n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses
ils mènent le monde à sa perte et en
droit en gros ils veulent des candidats
à nouveau des candidats frais et en plus
avec une forme de respectabilité parce
que sander s'il est dans la vie
politique depuis toujours et
automatiquement il a une forme de
crédibilité il a il a la niaque on fasse
est très difficile de faire une campagne
surtout aux états unis qui est un pays
tellement grand et à son âge
enfin c'est pareil pour bayonne mais
deux campagnes de suite c'est juste
épuisant demande même comment ces
personnes qui a donc du coup aujourd'hui
on voit bien que les candidats dit un
peu populiste un peu hors établissements
aux états unis comme ailleurs sont en
train de l'emporter
et rappelez vous quand vous et moi ya
pas si longtemps on avait moins de 18
ans aux moins de 25 ans on est quand
même plus prompts à voter pour un
candidat qui est en dehors du cadre que
de celui qu'on ne respecte pas qui est
qui qui incarne le carde est à vie donc
ce n'est pas très étonnant est
effectivement paul a aussi raison il
faut faire très attention jusqu'ici les
jeunes ne votaient pas et on a vu aux
élections européennes que les jeunes ont
voté d'ailleurs ils ont voté assez
largement pour des candidats à faire et
aux etats unis ces candidats qu'on voit
dans le music on a vu avec sander ceseda
sont des candidats qui arrive à
bousculer les habitudes c'est pour ça je
disais clé les gens sont un peu perdus
parce que tout à coup des gens qui ne
votait pas zot et donc c'est ça qui perd
un petit peu les commentateurs dr house
alors les démocrates 1 sont donc à
perdre
et aux urnes dans six états ce mardi je
vous propose justement d'écouter deux
électeurs à détroit dans le michigan qui
parle de ce match soit de loin le sujet
le plus important pour moi et c'est qui
peut battre le président trump un voire
deux siègent à la cour suprême vont être
choisis par le prochain président et je
pense que le vice président biden a plus
de chance pour battre donald trump et
l'emporter dans des états comme le
michigan
je pense que ça risque d'être une course
serrée le sénateur sanders a
certainement beaucoup de soutiens dans
le michigan et c'est justifié
c'est un candidat qui inspire beaucoup
de gens mais le michigan a aussi un côté
pragmatique et donc j'espère que le
michigan va soutenir le vice-président
maiden je vote pour son dherse pour sa
constance au cours des 40 dernières
années
sans programme visant à restaurer la
classe moyenne est vraiment tout ce pour
quoi elle s'est battue au cours de sa
vie je soutiens tout ça vous savez je
suis optimiste et j'ai fait partie des
électeurs qui ont aidé à le faire élire
en 2016 je veux dire à lui faire gagner
la primaire dans le michigan
on avait été ignorée à l'époque mais
j'ai de l'espoir pour aujourd'hui on en
a pas encore parlé ici mais il ya
vraiment un pragmatisme et d'une
certaine manière un vote utile bernie
sanders est un petit peu l'affect le
côté enthousiasmant et joe biden un vote
utile celui qui serait le plus à même
d'affronter votre candidat par reed d'un
trompe vous d'ailleurs vous avez quel
préférence vous préféreriez cris
finalement ni l'un ni l'autre en fait
j'ai confiance que dans deux chambres à
gagner soit parce que c'est toi le
candidat vous craignez pas un petit peu
plus je baille donne quand même
peut-être rien c'est pas quand même vous
avouer n'importe sa série serrée parce
que l'élection générale s'est inséré
parce que le pays est tellement division
2 mais le fait est que le parti
démocrate est divisée en deux et le
parti républicain et 95 pressent
derrière qui soutient dans notre chambre
on ya vraiment un enthousiasme
d'empathie républicain cette course
primé entre joe bein c'est intéressant à
voir mais comme leader jean de détroit a
bien dit l'établissement
joe bar mc c'est pas un candidat fort
oublie que il était presque fini pendant
le prime 1 avant la carabine sur le
monde surnomme john woo s'est alors j'ai
avoir du mal à vous le traduire en
anglais le mot quand on immobilise
mais c'est vrai que il est clair que ça
c'est pas mouiller
il fait des gaffes et ses gaffes et les
gars aujourd'hui il a ici montre ici
discuter avec nous je sais pas si vous
avez lu mais il était en train train de
visiter une usine automotive a dit ware
il s'est disputé avec une employée et
avec vos gars étaient avec profane et
est donc le meilleur dans une débat
quand il parle pas quand obama savait ça
obama ces deux cas chez jo et maintenant
tout l'établissement est derrière un
candidat anti jo donc il soutient dubaï
parce que peut-être il croit qu'il peut
gagner contre caen mais non mais non et
on verra le départ le 15 mars ils
rendent bas entre boni ni jo bein et
l'infusion oui derrière bris mais c'est
pas le moitié c'est moins de la moitié
de la partie dans guingouin fortes sur
de fortes chances que ben haim va gagner
mais pendant un débat on verra que
barney est beaucoup plus fort en public
en discours est beaucoup plus claire que
jobs ait donc rien finit rien n'est
décidé pour denis jacquet sur cette
notion de vote utile celui qui serait le
plus à même d'affronter donald trump
vous partager la vie de notre ami
pèlerine sur ce plateau
alors ouais en fait pas ne se prononçait
pas sur l'un ou l'autre moi je pour le
côté show je pense qu'un débat entre
donald trump et bernie sanders
je pense que ça aura été un truc
extraordinaire sur scène parce que
j'imagine déjà les répliques
l'affrontement une espèce de forme de
d'attac d'agressivité ex tard je pense
que pour le show la qualité du show
excusez moi si je raisonne purement
images et les moments télévisuels
ça aurait été un truc extraordinaire
parce que joe biden c'est comme un
politique assez à l'ancienne dans sa
façon de parler de communiquer de
pointer du doigt et c'est tous les codes
de de l'ancienne génération alors que
sanders est très difficile à prendre
pour quelqu'un comme pour quelqu'un
comme trump à ce que c'est très
difficile d'être face à trump pour
quelqu'un de plus policé et ses come by
donne ça va être un peu plus compliqué
alors que pour sanders il va entrer
dedans il va renvoyer la balle
moi j'aurais adoré assister à ce type de
débat c'est pas fini denis jacquet vous
semblez ne plus y croire
j'ai du mal à y croire parce qu'à un
moment donné et là je rejoins paul c'est
que l'établissement le super structure
ne veux pas me laisser en termes de
report de voix comme si ces déçus faut
pas oublier que c'est pas le peuple qui
vote ils volent pour des électeurs qui à
leur tour décide mais néanmoins autant
c'est facile pour quelqu'un
éventuellement qui a voté pour sanders
se dire bonjour quand même faire gagner
mon temps mon camp en face à trump et je
suis quand même voter paille donne
autant il ya des gens pour qui vraiment
goûté sanders ça va être trop compliqué
et donc je pense que le phénomène de
report de voix risque de marché beaucoup
plus en faveur de bayonne qu'en faveur
de sanders mais bon on verra on verra ce
que disent les jours prochains mais il a
quand même un gros écart à remonter ça
me paraît assez insurmontable non c'est
effectivement on sait pas ce qui peut se
passer ça peut être très surprenant
alors l'état qu'on va guetter le plus
intérêt de ce soir c'est le michigan on
rappelle que bernie sanders avait gagné
lors des dernières primaires démocrates
s'étaient en 2016 contre hillary clinton
dans cet état c'est un état très
important par laurine me l'ouest et les
employeurs
le travailleur les usines antimissile
crise automobile en 2008
mais c'est bien que vous avez bien dit
qu'il ya à gagner contre lui mais il lui
est en tête dans tous les sondages
cependant avant primes et michigan et
c'était une suprise premier a gagné
finalement parce que pourquoi parce qu'
il n'était pas été mauvaise candidats et
qu' il y avait cette pop you're in que
monsieur jacquet a parlé que anti
établissements y avait un mouvement
propre il propulse aux états unis depuis
quatre ans un petit établissement et je
crois que le parti démocrate oublie ça
un peu à ce que
encore nominé il voudrait une candidat
établissements et c'est vraiment
brillante chance mais une petite chance
à gagner le michigan soit du global
gagne et c'est presque le finit toujours
par bernie parce que la fin pour but
mais si boeing peut être juste
compétitive parce qu'ils partagent des
délégués ça peut donner un peu de
deuxième main et peut continuer alors
une information qui nous est parvenu il
ya quelques minutes
denis jacquet bernie sanders qui annule
un meeting à cause du coronavirus aussi
aux états unis a pas qu'en france c'est
une première dans la campagne est ce que
denis jacquet aux états unis.le
coronavirus prend autant de place dans
l'actualité que chez nous en france c
est ce qui peut peser parce qu'on
rappelle quand même que l'élection c'est
en novembre à ce que d'ici là vous
craignez aux états unis qu'il pèse
fortement sur cette campagne
présidentielle voir qui de la perturbe
écouter alors on espère tous en lien
dans ce que je vais vous dire il ya du
il ya du souhait est un peu de réalité
on pense tous que les pics vont être
atteints en tout cas pour la france et
pour l'italie a priori l'italie mais ça
s'est encore aggravée hier mais que les
pics vont être atteints dans les quinze
jours trois semaines qui viennent et
qu'ensuite on sera dans une phase
d'arrondissement et de baisse donc on
est tous a priori dans d'après
l'information qu'on a dans une
dans une séquence dans lequel à partir
de fin mai début juin la vie devrait
revenir à peu près normal donc comme la
campagne en beaucoup de place dans les
médias américains ce qui est assez
logique
le virus en prend un peu moins mais
cette dernière semaine il ya eu beaucoup
d'interventions y compris du président
trump sur le sujet puisque ce matin on
apprenait qu'une ou deux personnes de
son entourage pouvait être affectés donc
ça devient vraiment un sujet de
préoccupation forte et notamment de
savoir d'ailleurs c'est une question que
je me pose puisque j'arrive en france
dans quelques jours de savoir si je dois
renvoyer à g ici si je pourrai le faire
dans un mois
non et ça devient vraiment très
préoccupante et aux états unis comme
ailleurs parce que les états unis c'est
un pays où on voyage c'est un pays où il
y avait beaucoup de transit et gens qui
viennent de partout encore aujourd'hui
est donc bien évidemment les états unis
sont pas à l'abri mais à nouveau on
parle d'une élection en fin d'année donc
il y aura des répercussions pendant
quelques semaines et puis après
heureusement les choses vont entrer dans
mon entrée dans l'ordre alors qu'on
apprend également que joe biden à son
tour annuler un meeting de campagne
alors vous dites voilà l'épidémie va
passer il ya des répercussions sur la
campagne
enfin il ya autre chose qui est très
important surtout aux états unis surtout
pour donald trump c'est l'état des
marchés financiers
ça peut tout changer un le corps en à
virieu son lancer qui a créé hier un
lundi noir sur toutes les bourses
mondiales new york y compris ça ça peut
vraiment faire basculer la donne de
cette élection par laurine aux états
unis
une crise économique ça peut tout
changer et c'est vrai donc ça vous
inquiète justement tant que républicain
parce que moi je crois que le plupart
des humains qu'un par le parti démocrate
et des américains républicains mais ça
nous inquiète pour votre candidat trump
1 pour sa réélection parce que non non
je suis donc quoique la majorité des
humains qui ne met pas le blâme sur
danone
c'est une virus c'est un événement à
externe qui est globale qui crée des
problèmes dans tous les pays et entre
ces deux leaders et dont les actions et
dans les actions et a déjà donné depuis
fin janvier de thé traiter les problèmes
de frontières et à fermer la frontière
avec la chine
en fin janvier avec iron et acide il
travaille avec cdc qui est l'intro de
maladie aux états unis et mettre tout
les idées sur la table pour trouver des
solutions tout vaccin aider les gens
donc je crois que le plus bas des 5 1
voix
mais un autre côté le parti démocrate
et c'est évidemment de politis et pour
l'utiliser politisé et d'attiser le
christ dit que c'est pas les coronavirus
et les 30 virus qui tue sa faute
donc on croisait les doigts je crois que
c'est une panique est nécessaire je ne
sais pas si monsieur jacquet voir si aux
états unis est en panique crier et c'est
dommage c'est pas nécessaire
1 denis jacquet justement le mot de la
fin parce que les américains comment il
juge cette gestion de donald trump alors
c'est intéressant mais c'est vrai que il
ya dû avoir beaucoup de panique du côté
des états unis aussi
avec ces bourses qui qui s'écroule
est-ce qu'on attend beaucoup du
président des états unis
je pense que pour le moment l'ambiance
générale c'est que l'économie
trump a pendant le moment bénéficié d'un
espèce de traîne qui étaient plutôt
positives qui venait de du gouvernement
d'avant d'obama mais il a su amplifiée
par des mesures fiscales par un certain
nombre de l'investissement qu'il a fait
prolonger et amplifier ce qui fait qu'on
arrive effectivement à -2 4 % de chômage
qui était pas arrivé depuis les années
60 donc à nouveau set pour revenir ce
que je disais au départ il ya deux
catégories à tous ceux dans les grandes
piles ou villes moyennes grandes qui ont
bénéficié de ça qui aujourd'hui ont un
job pas forcément un job de rêve pas
forcément payer mais au moins ils ont un
job ils sont à l'abri et ceux là peuvent
continuer à faire confiance à un treuil
je pense qu'ils envoient tron pour leur
vie et puis il ya ceux qui a tenté un
job
les mineurs qui ont vu effectivement des
usines à charbon secret mais sans emploi
parce qu'ils étaient mécanisée ou
d'autres qui n'ont pas vu cette pub de
secret qui vont à mon avis glisser plus
tôt vers l'électorat un petit peu
populiste quant au marché c'est une
autre affaire en fait ils ont perdu hier
énormément j'ai regardé qu'aujourd'hui
ils ont repris tout ce qu'ils avaient
perdu hier donc ce qui m'importe plus
c'est quel va être l'impact définitif de
ce virus en termes de croissance
et si ces points de croissance perdue
qui s'est vraiment une récession à une
crise profonde
là les cartes ouvert pourrait
éventuellement être battu d'ici la
présidence américaine mais il faudrait
vraiment un effondrement très important
et je pense moi personnellement j'ai pas
d'avis particulier ni de choix
particulier parce que pour l'instant je
suis français et j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'avis particulier mais je pense comme
paul vraisemblablement que à condition
égale aujourd'hui le président trump
l'emportera pour la deuxième fois
denis jacquet en d'agde
mamie pèlerine ici sur ce plateau s'est
inversée des américains à paris les
français s'étaient jenny merci à vous